event i was in las vegas when this took
place out of nowhere when trump wrote it
on truth network where we just got the
mar-a-lago was rated
fbi agents came in they took you know a
number of boxes 27 boxes removed from
mar-a-lago
11 of which contain classified documents
as what they're saying four sets were
marked as top secret three of them were
marked at secret and three others were
marked confidential
and then you hear all this stuff and
then trump says on truth social number
one it was all declassified
number two they didn't need to seize
anything they could have had any had at
any time they wanted without playing
politics and breaking into mar-a-lago it
was in a secret storage with an
additional lock put on as per their
request they could have it had it any
time they wanted and that includes long
ago all they had to do was ask the
bigger problem is what are they going to
do with the 33 million pages of
documents
many of which are classified that
president obama took to chicago and then
as some are saying it's uh some nuclear
information was there and then they said
why wouldn't the fbi allow the
inspection of areas of mar-a-lago with
our lawyers or others present made them
wait outside in the heat wouldn't let
them get even closer absolutely not so
the
the insinuation the claims they're
making is there may have been some
nuclear documentation in there
potentially but when you saw this what
was the first thought
well
most people have their mind made up on
trump already nobody nobody's going to
be watching this and being like okay
based on this story how do i feel about
trump you either feel that he is a
national treasurer or national hero and
that's what side you're on or that you
think that he's a national security risk
straight up so
you know if you want to kind of look at
the left and the right on this you can
say all right this is politically trying
to reason exactly try to reason i mean
i'm just trying to be in the middle here
just try to reason most of america you
know they're weaponizing the justice
department and then it's basically just
sort of political theater and that or
then there's other side of the coin
that's basically saying no these are
legitimate concerns these are very
serious charges what are they breaking
the espionage act and yeah and you know
basically obstruction of justice
so um at the end of the day everything's
gonna fall on merrick garland he's the
one who signed off on this i think the
first couple days they were like how did
this happen who's the person the doj
what's going on
garland who infamously was passed up for
a supreme court justice under obama
mitch mcconnell we all know that story
oh no no he got over that yeah exactly
so is it
is it feeling better now right but i
don't think he took this lightly when
he's and i'm not oh no merrick garland
personally i don't know where his
mentality is at but when he signs off on
this
he has to realize oh [ __ ] this is some
serious you know you don't think we're
reading the the home of the president ex
president united states you don't think
by noon
i don't know i don't want to expect it
so
let me let me ask you questions i mean i
generally don't know percentage-wise i
know you don't know but percentage-wise
so think about it if you're going to do
something garland you're going to do
something for the first time and it's
never
ever
happened before ever you got it happened
before and it's under your watch as a
president yeah would you want me garland
to call you or would you want me to do
without calling you if you're saying or
is it likely that by new yes it's
probably likely i don't know so it sort
of comes out so it is likely that he
knew likely if you didn't know what does
it say let's just say he didn't know if
biden didn't know what does he say about
biden
who's running the show it shows weak
leadership if you don't know first of
all
for you to go out there i don't know for
the record i don't know what biden knew
or didn't know i'm just saying that this
comes on to for merrick garland he's the
one who signed off on this he's the
attorney general i i get that but the
department of justice falls under him
i'm talking did biden know yeah maybe i
don't know but we don't know that yet
that's not what i'm asking you try to
reason with me so if he didn't know okay
assume you're biden i'm garland
i do this
knowing the opposing side is gonna say
well you know they're trying to hurt
their number one contender etc etc would
you not want to know before i do
something different agree with you yes
so you would probably want to know now
if i said i guarantee that he knows i
don't know now let me ask you a second
second question say i intentionally did
it without telling you that'd be messed
up correct not only would it be messed
up but secondly it would mean what
you're a nobody that you don't have
control that you don't have control so
just so you know if they take the
position of oh biden had nothing to do
with it weak leadership if they take the
position off
exactly lose lose no matter which way so
that one is the next one now here's the
other part
if it's so classified why'd you wait 18
months that is the one thing for me
forget all the conspiracies forget
everything i have one question if we're
really here just to protect we the
people whoever that is
of whatever party at whatever time in
history it's really here to protect we
the people why wait 18 months i erase
all the conspiracies everything like
that i even reasoned in my mind just
like you said divided no did he not no
good lord what's going on here but i
come down to why did you wait till now
if this was really a problem and you
were really worried about that woman who
coulda or probably was a chinese spy
with the the the hidden camera the
hidden camera in mar-a-lago that they
found that they found while ago says oh
my gosh there were there was a potential
chinese asset there 18 20 30 months ago
it was a potential chinese asset this
could be classified stuff we got to go
over there right now isn't that the way
the government should respond
so why do we wait until now
why well they have had communication
with trump's lawyers they didn't just
come out of nowhere apparently they were
like hey you got to return the whatever
and then he's like yeah we've already
done adam adam let's let's reason
through this point you're right there
was a lot of
reasoning and discussion done and back
and forth back and forth but if it was a
national security issue of nuclear
secrets of level one there is no
reasoning it's go protect the republic
and bust down the door including the one
with the extra lock and get that stuff
and put it someplace safe secure so that
that to me that to me sounds reasonable
to do that right if it's if if you're
saying it's such a national security you
know risk
you waiting 18 months shows a lack of
responsibility and leadership again so
go both ways go say
it is
okay and you waited 18 months weak
leadership go say it's not and then you
waited you so both ways you're losing
leadership and irresponsible yeah weak
leadership and irresponsible the other
part is when uh andrew cuomo comes out
and he says
hang on a second he comes out and he
says you must immediately explain the
reason for its rate and it must be more
than a search of inconsequential uh
archives or it will be viewed as a
political tactic and undermine any
future credible investigation on the
legitimacy of january 6th investigation
this is what cuomo said now
a pundit came out and said the following
cuomo is wrong doj doesn't have to
explain anything they never announced
they searched mar-a-lago trump did he's
the one who politicized it by stealing
documents
refusing to return the documents and
pretending to be the victim after he
broke the law okay so that's the
argument being made and cuomo by the way
is a guy that can't stand trump for him
to say what he's saying so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]